[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vu
l'émission débat de l'actualité posez
vos questions réagissez nous répercutons
vos commentaires en direct l'actualité
c'est la fin des voitures à essence à
paris x d'anne hidalgo
ce sera pour 2030 et ça ne plaît pas à
tout le monde loin de là c'est dans
moins longtemps dans deux mois chez les
républicains l'élection de leur
président sur le papier laurent wauquiez
a déjà gagné mais la bagarre au sein de
la droite ne cesse de s'amplifier
on va en parler mélenchon valls les deux
hommes politiques risquent un jour d'en
venir aux mains c'est tous les jours que
le patron de la france insoumise
provoque l'ancien premier ministre
on verra sur quoi et jean luc mélenchon
encore lui qui s'en prend aussi au
drapeau européen
l'adepte des hologrammes une fois une
apparition de la vierge c'est sa
nouvelle croisade
bonjour olivier duhamel linge au jeu
rist politologue bienvenue dans point de
vue bienvenue dans ce débat vous venez
de publier
macron et en même temps c'est écrit avec
laurent bigorgne et alice beaudry et ça
vient de sortir chez plon bonjour
laurent bouvet vous êtes politologue
universitaire directoire de l'obs
directeur de l'observatoire de la vie
politique à la fondation jean jaurès
fondation proche du parti socialiste
et vous êtes aussi à l'origine du
mouvement printemps républicain et vous
êtes l'auteur de la gauche sont bi
chronique d'une malédiction politique
c'est paru chez lemieux
bonjour paul quinio rédacteur en chef à
l'ops l'ops qui titre cette semaine avec
cette question qui veut la peau hidalgo
ça tombe bien on va en parler
et bonjour alexis brézet des lecteurs
des rédactions du figaro merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous alors pour se mettre en
jambes si je puis dire je vous propose
de parler voiture ou plutôt absence de
voitures en 2030 c'est demain vous
viendrez tous les cathos figaro à pied à
au vélo ou peut-être en voiture
électrique la voiture à essence en tout
cas ce sera fini quant au diesel il sera
parti à la casse depuis longtemps c'est
en tout cas la dernière volume volonté
certains diront lubie d'anne hidalgo
regardez ce conditions l'adjoint
christophe nadjovski c'était ce matin
sur france info
on est sur une planification à 12 ans on
a des progrès énormes qu'ils sont en
train d'être effectués sur le véhicule
électrique
on a également la perspective du
véhicule autonome
qui va peut être révolutionné aussi nos
transports on est en train de vivre en
réalité une véritable révolution en
matière de mobilité et donc ce que nous
essayons simplement c'est d'anticiper
aussi cette évolution de nous inscrire
aussi dans la nécessité de la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
question du climat n'attend pas et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
fait un peu cette perspective qui est à
la fois au chili en même temps
relativement loin visionner la raison ni
lingots le climat n'attend pas disons
qu'il ya des arguments assez fort mais
qui a quand même au moins un problème
c'est que c'est un peu une attitude je
dirais d'indépendantistes catalan parce
que certes 60 % des parisiens n'ont pas
de voiture mais la circulation
automobile privé dans paris elle est
absolument indispensable à un très grand
nombre de banlieusards et donc interdire
la voiture ce serait très provoqué de
très grandes difficultés pour cela alors
sauf si on mettait en place mais
personne ne parle de ça des vrais plans
de création de vastes parkings tout
autour de l'est de la grande métropole
pour que les banlieues a pu s'approcher
de la capitale est immédiatement
enclenché ce un moyen de transport
commode mais tel que c'est annoncé si
c'est un coup du même genre que les
voies sur berge juste pour faire plaisir
à des parisiens contre les autres
franchement oui je trouve ça un peu
j'aime pas l'expression cas talibans
enfin été réaliste on va dire est libre
et c'est quelque chose de très juste il
dit qu'à une minorité de fond d'eux
parisien qui donc une voiture ils
utilisent ce ce que gianni la gouache
fois dire regardez les sondages je suis
à prouver d'abord il ya quand même
quelque chose d'un peu curieux oui c'est
une minorité mais après tout les
minorités même 40% c'est pas une petite
minorité
les minorités sont respectables on nous
parle toujours des droits des minorités
des droits minorité mais la minorité
d'automobilistes déjà absolument
condamnable et qui devrait être
exterminés et et pourquoi parce que
c'est un projet est pour moi j'ai
compris le dimanche dernier en discutant
avec abidal go et son entourage
après le grand jury c'est un projet qui
est un projet absolument idéologique
le problème c'est pas la pollution quand
on leur dit mais il ya des voitures
électriques pourquoi vous faites pas les
quais de la seine fait les pour les
voitures électriques
ils finissent par dire non mais bon bien
sûr il ya pollution mais le problème
c'est la voiture c'est la voiture
individuelle
à la limite la voiture autonome la
voiture collective la voiture qu'on
partage sa celle là pourquoi pas mais la
voiture individuelle je parle pas d'un
idéal go personnellement mais en tout
cas de notamment désert qui l'entourent
c'est idéologiquement quelque chose qui
est considéré comme absolument
condamnable cesse de propriété privée
bourgeoise qui accapare l'espace public
et ils font ce raisonnement qui est
bizarre et 10 mais est-ce que vous êtes
rendu compte que 70 %
l'espace public est réservé aux voitures
il n'ya pas y'a pas 70% d'automobilistes
oui enfin on pourrait dire que 100 %
d'espacé rien réservé aux avions c est
drôle qu'il faudrait autant d' espaces
pour les voitures que pour les piétons
que pour les vélos
c'est donc une vraiment une notion de
idéologique de récupération sur des gens
qui accapare un bien public ont marqué
la police mais les moyens de sa
situation c'est l'abolition d'une
circulation exalté matin est forte houle
et de leur mauvais projet idéologique il
planty policier il ya une
au moment où la gauche le parti
socialiste avec les verts
essentiellement et quelques autres
partis plus petits ont gagné la mairie
de paris en 2001 avec bertrand de la
noue et puis on suit donc jusqu'à
maintenant avec anne hidalgo
les verts sont devenus comme le parti
communiste l'été avant la pointe avancée
du combat progressiste c'est à dire que
les socialistes et ça déteint d'ailleurs
sur le parti socialiste qui explique en
grande partie aussi les problèmes du
parti social c'est-à-dire qu'avant les
socialistes il est bon on est
révolutionnée on est on est pour le
socialisme bon enfin il ya les
communistes et les vrais quand même bon
mais on nous on veut pas faire la
révolution mais on est plus calme et
enfin bon on partage les vues comme un
fin du communisme mur de berlin
arrive la question écologique qui
devient pour la gauche le grand progrès
du 21e siècle et dans cette question
écologique effectivement je suis tout à
fait d'accord cette idéologique la
voiture et le la pièce à abattre de la
vieille société industrielle dans
laquelle on doit sortir la voiture
privée mais oui mais nous étions privés
la position non non non parce que le
problème de la pollution
il ya eu un rapport il ya deux de trois
jours d'airparif qui est à airparif
c'est un organisme indépendant
indépendant mais c'est un organisme qui
est pas éloigné de la mairie paris mon
pote pas un organisme de par exemple du
conseil régional d'ile-de-france qui
serait contre l'amérique par tant ses
conclusions sur les urgences explique
sur les voies sur berge
la pollution a diminué avec le plus dur
est évidemment il ya plus de voitures
mais mais qu'elle s'est reportée et
quand on explique ça moi j'ai ce débat
très souvent avec des gens qui sont pour
les mesures anti voiture je leur dis
mais le report de la pollution montre
que c'est pas un problème de pollution
c'est ce que disait alexis brisé par
exemple il n'ya pas de covoiturage sur
les voies sur berge il n'y a pas de
réserve
on réserve pas les voies sur berge au
covoiturage ou avec avec des lignes
comme ça serait dans tous les pays du
monde
si vous êtes plus de 2 dans la voiture
vous avez droit d'utiliser les voies sur
berge si vous n'êtes pas + 2 vous êtes
sanctionné
donc ça veut dire effectivement cette
idéologie que c'est la voiture privée
qui est le problème
et cette question est une question
éminemment politique pourquoi parce que
considéré que tous les parisiens qui ont
une voiture cette minorité de 40% sont
des des entre guillemets pardonnez moi
moi j'appelle ça des nazis mobilisent
c'est à dire des gens qui sont des
[ __ ] parce qu'ils ont une voiture
parce qu'ils ont besoin de leur voiture
parce que donc je rigole mais c'est un
terme caricatural année en algérie
cette idée c'est idée que ces gens sont
doivent être effectivement contrées que
politique monétaire or ces gens là et on
pourrait faire le test très facilement
et moi je te le feu par là de mon
exemple on fait aussi du vélo on prend
aussi les transports en commun on a des
enfants on n'a pas envie de les voir
mourir de pollution nos enfants enfin je
veux dire cette idée que de toute façon
parce qu'on est une voiture on est
quelqu'un de totalement irresponsable
qui veut tuer ses enfants fin voyez
c'est j'exagère je caricature les
seconds je donne également les réactions
de nos internautes qui sont
effectivement nombreux à réagir sur ce
sujet par exemple flot du pot qui nous
dit pourquoi vouloir tuer l'industrie
automobile à essence ou non d'un certain
paysagisme parisien alors que
l'infrastructure pour les voitures
électriques n'est pas au point ça c'est
quelque chose qui revient souvent
d'ailleurs la victoire des bornes qui
n'existe pas pour recharger les voitures
alain qui se posent la question
électrons structure est automobile
qu'est ce qu'ils en disent et sandrine
22 castle paris est devenue une belle
cata pour ceux qui viennent de
l'extérieur y travaillent ont rejoint la
problématique des personnes arrivent en
banlieue la maladie du stress au travail
est pire que la pollution
paul quinio locks on le disait et fait
sa couverture sur sur anne hidalgo simon
qui veut sa peau c'est quoi la réponse
c'est une partie du ca a été dit là
précédemment c'est une partie du
fictivement ce qu'on appelle aussi le
lobby automobile
on parle de l'automobile club de france
et effectivement c'est tous les gens qui
refusent de d'imaginer que la révolution
en cours autour de la voiture électrique
est d'aider futur mode de transport peut
être une opportunité c'est là où je
trouve qu'on a un petit peu évacuer trop
vite tous les arguments autour de la
pollution qui est quand même réel et de
de ne pas considérer comme une chance le
fait de pouvoir changer de modèle et de
d'inciter les constructeurs automobiles
parce qu'évidemment qui sont pas
d'accord aujourd'hui mais il n'était pas
d'accord non plus il ya dix ans et donc
et qui est que si on les écoute les
choses ne changent ne changeront jamais
et les mêmes qui râlent est il ya dix
ans quand bertrand delanoë il ya 15 ans
a fait les les couloirs de bus les
textes si raleigh je pense que les taxis
sont aujourd'hui les premiers satisfait
de ce qui a été fait donc jeu et je
trouve que le côté un petit peu comme ça
on dit plus de voitures en 2030 et un
petit côté utopique
1 je trouve que c'est aussi les utopies
qui parfois font avancer le
les choses en politique est par ailleurs
on peut pas d'un côté applaudir quand
françois hollande signent l'accord sur
de la com 21 et 2 et 2 et de râler quand
à lindahl gaumais femme propose une
mesure qui est d'une certaine manière
une concrétisation de cet accord la
contradiction effectivement remboursé
par la critique c'est pas parce qu'on
considère que la politique choisie par
anne hidalgo de d'aller directement
frontalement contre les automobiles de
les prendre comme cible est de faire des
mesures extrêmement cédant ses 90 ans je
parle à la fois des voies sur berges de
cette annonce de cette annonce est
générale
ce sont les remparts if le dit ça ne
réduit pas la pollution ça déplace la
circulation c'est un autre organisme
citadine qui contrôlent la circulation
et les mouches ou en ile-de-france alors
ouvert au public s'il mesure aussi
radicale exemple imaginer attendait
basculeront quand même de la voiture âgé
entière à la voiture électrique mais là
là je parle de la manière dont c'est
fait aujourd'hui et citadine mesure le
nombre de bouchons qui a augmenté depuis
que le centre de la métropole compte
tenu de la manière dont est organisé le
réseau routier et les difficultés du
réseau des transports publics est saturé
en attendant le métro du grand paris etc
on a mis un peu la charrue avant les
boeufs ciblées or il ya d'autres grandes
villes comparables à paris qui ont
choisi d'éliminer la pollution de
d'interdire dans leur centre c'est le
cas de long de nos colonnes les vieilles
voitures polluantes depuis très
longtemps
tokyo pédagos tokyo non pas du tout elle
n'a pas fait elle a commencé par
interdire de circuler sur certaines
voies sur les grandes voies tokyo
interdit il ya trente ans les voitures
diesel ça a fait changer l'industrie
automobile toyota qui le premier
producteur mondial aujourd'hui ne
produit pas de voitures diesel c'est le
premier à 7 me à l'hybride par exemple
donc là on a des effets industriels qui
sont des choix qui aujourd'hui sont des
choix qui apparaissent comme avec paris
seul pas le grand paris pas la région
ile-de-france pas avec l'êta pas encore
pas en concertation madame hidalgo
seules les villes monde
de sa petite ville de 2 millions
d'habitants paris entouré par son
périphérique ville monde qui va imposer
sa loi à l'industrie automobile etc
ça n'a aucun sens donc c'est ça qui est
critiquable c'est pas l'objectif final
c'est pas logique vous avez entendu car
bien sûr expliqué qu'il mettait la
priorité j'avais vu sur la fabrication
des crêpes à ce que j'allais dire et
c'est pour ça que c'est pas contre le
bon c'est pour ça c'est parce qu'ils
savaient dix ans après un chrono à
choisir il ya le lot de mieux nous
finançons frais ou de carlos ghosn un
grand détail figure obligée pour dire
bien été question dans cinq ans 50 % de
notre gamme pas de ne débuter qu'on
vendra désormais de notre gamme sera
électrique donc lui il y à tête mais
encore celle qui chante en sont at il du
vent des îles actions d'amélioration
justement ils l'ont fait après si c'est
après la panne est il vraiment des
mesures assez terrifiant c'est tout à
fait bien elle même c'est pourquoi des
mesures d'interdiction on pourrait
inciter je le répète si aujourd'hui on
disait la voix les voies sur berge entre
l'ouest de paris et le centre de paris
sont réservées pas au vélo mais aux
voitures électriques ça inciterait les
habitants notamment de l'ouest de paris
à s'équiper en voitures électriques là
on a choisi de les mettre des vélos et
on va se rendre compte qu'il ya quand
même très peu de gens qui se promènent
sur les quais en vélo toute la journée
c'est pas vrai l'aventuré avec ceux qui
ont des vélos qui sont dans les
embouteillages avec le réseau cbc des
bijoux qui paul meilhat il ya quelques
années un argument est un argument avec
lequel je suis pas d'accord c'est quand
vous disais tout à l'heure que c'est pas
l'objectif con con
qu'on refuse je parle pas nous mais je
pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de gens
qui refusent de bouger qu'il faut
qu'elle va réagir sur la pollution et
pour la pollution a requis mais qui en
tout cas qui ne veut quiquine si on les
écoutait rien n'aurait bougé depuis 20
ans et c'est là où je trouve que
le encore une fois le fait de mettre la
barre très haut et de ça permet de faire
bouger les curseurs et d'avancer il est
vrai que l'adversaire plus bêtes que les
autres ça c'est fort possible existence
politique mais tout le monde n'est pas
justement à refuser quand on a des
enfants on a soi même peut-être des
problèmes respiratoires etc
personne n'est pour la pollution à
continuer à s' il faut aussi atteinte
faut penser ça les rassure on parlait
tout à l'heure des transports en commun
on sait que voilà il ya des choses qui
sont en cours et qui vont vous qu'ils
vont changer qui vont s'ouvrir à des
talons tout ça tout ça tout ça c'est
qu'elle semble de concevoir une
politique de transport à l'échelle du
pays
barry et grèce devait faire six autres
exemples la journée la journée sont nuls
à la fin c'était il ya quelques gars
quinze jours il avait un dimanche sans
voiture il bon pourquoi pas pourquoi est
ce que les transports en commun sont pas
gratuits enfin alors toujours des
réactions sur la florian qui nous dit la
voiture dans la tête des progressistes
représente l'ancien monde salle bruyante
plein de négativité comme l'a très bien
montré philippe murray flot du pont qui
revient il nous dit qu'anne hidalgo veut
faire de paris une ville comme venise ou
amsterdam sans avoir lu la contrainte
des canaux mais la contrainte des
distances avec le risque grévistes des
transports en commun et serge châtelet
je ne vois pas les parisiens partir en
week-end avec une voiture électrique et
m 18 heures pour aller à l'heure la
question du jour du figaro en tout cas
là aussi une large majorité à 64% de
d'internautes défavorable à
l'intervention de la voiture à essence
tant paris s'est pour le moment
le score obtenu par notre question du
jour les républicains l'élection à la
présidence du parti c'est dans deux mois
le 10 décembre prochain
laurent wauquiez on le sait et le super
favori mais il n'a pas on le sait aussi
que des amis parmi les adversaires
déclarait le chiraquien jean louis debré
l'ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale flingue à tout va écouter le
ils parlent de leur entrepôt pied le
gaullisme
arras est parti avec général de gaulle
et avec ses compagnons il n'a pas à
revendiquer d'être le fils spirituel de
untel ou untel
laissons les discours parler à la place
des professions de foi elle explore
invoquée c'est le bonhomme à la bonne
place d'autres aujourd'hui c'est le seul
en d'autres façons il faudra bien que je
pense au fond que toutes ces critiques
de la turquie ne supporte pas laurent
wauquiez notamment pour des raisons
historiques ou de personnalités qui
estime qu'il n'est pas fiable sa non pas
une immense importance si sa maman femme
ne se passe à la question n'est pas là
la question c'est est-ce que
wauquiez va réussir à reconstruire et à
recréer un lien avec les électeurs et
cette question à l'ailier notes et à les
lieux ont semble-t-il principalement
qu'est ce qui va se passer du côté de
mâcon est ce que macron pas réussi
auquel cas il y aura plus d espace pour
laurent wauquiez pour longtemps est ce
que voyant un reflux excuse à ce moment
là me wauquiez sera capable d'être le
réceptacle de ce refus à presque 10
pierpoljak moi j'écoute j'ai quand même
connu l'époque on disait fachos chirac
l'époque on disait sarkozy sectaire
sarkozy c'est l'homme seul c'est pas ça
qui compte
ou on est en situation et on essaie
faire venir un électorat et les
dirigeants ils suivent toujours le
problème c'est pas les dirigeants c'est
les électeurs moi je serai un peu sur
est-ce que ce même si maintenant elles
seront réussies qui a une partie des
républicains qui vont vers macron pour
des raisons économiques sûr on voit bien
là les discussions sur le budget ou le
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
interpelle ses anciens camarades de de
la droite en disant vous ont fait les
mesures que vous avez toujours demandé
qu'on voit bien que je et mais c'est pas
là dessus que laurent wauquiez peut se
construire un espace politique c'est sur
des questions qui ne sont pas
précisément économique et sociale cds
question du conservatisme manière
générale social des questions de moeurs
etc
et puis les questions qu'on appelle
identitaire et là il ya un enjeu pour
lui c est ce qu'il va être capable de
reprendre et d'incarner au moment où il
y a quand même un vide qui s'est
constituée à sa droite au front national
avec l'échec de marine le pen à la
présidentielle face à son échec
personnel parce que le front national a
réalisé un bon score mais l'échec de sa
stratégie et on voit les difficultés
aujourd'hui laurent wauquiez un espace
politique qui va être de reconstituer ce
qu avaient peu ou prou quand même réussi
en grande partie dans avec une grande
ampleur beaucoup plus grand de nicolas
sarkozy en 2007 c'est-à-dire de réunir à
la fois le vote conservateur catholique
bourgeois et c'est disons et puis un
vote beaucoup plus populaires attaché à
la fois des questions identitaires lié à
la question sociale donc est ce qu'il va
être capable parce que sa macro ne le
traite pas et la gauche ne le traite pas
non plus donc est ce qu'il va être
capable de faire ce ce pas et
d'apparaître non pas comme simplement le
type qui devient le qui récupère le
front national qui est comme le front
national est avec lust racisme etc
mais être capable de reconstruire une
soeur
droite à la fois de national et
populaire qui s'installe et qui devient
qu'ils arrêtent
l'épisode historique du front national
en france et kirk heureux devient un
grand un grand parti sur la droite ça
c'est son nom sur ce positionnement
olivier duhamel qu'en sens commun
propose évoque une plate forme possible
avec marion maréchal-le pen ça c'est une
épine pour laurent wauquiez
oui c'est pas une belle excuse moi j'ai
juste une petite note en bas de page sur
jean-louis debré la wii aujourd'hui
devrait plus non juste quand il parle
des filiations s'est pas seulement par
rapport au gaullisme est adressé à
michel debré c'est aussi parce qu'il a
siégé très longtemps au conseil
constitutionnel avec jacques barrot et
jacques barrot était le parrain de
wauquiez c'est lui qui a entre
guillemets donné sa circonscription et
jacques barrot était un démocrate
chrétien très pro-européens il ça la
rendait absolument à la hâte de voir
bloquées devenir souverainiste est
beaucoup plus droitiers donc cette
explication vient de voile à cette
explication figaro live on est quand
même un certain niveau se permettre ce
genre de précisions pareil non moi je
pense que c'est très important cette
élection c'est pas parce qu'elle n'est
pas compétitive qu'elle n'est pas
importante que la droite a absolument
besoin de se doter d'un chef que
wauquiez va devenir va donner au moins
un chef de l'opposition à droite et
qu'on cessera d'être dans ce jeu
permanent entre mélenchon et mac rond
point barre et que le pays en a besoin
c'est une bonne chose
alors après la question jusqu'où est ce
qu'il va dans le sur la ligne
identitaire en flirtant presque avec les
thèses du front national
d'un point de vue strictement
d'efficacité politique il faut bien
reconnaître
quoi qu'on en pense sur le fond c'est à
votre sujet et ça ne m'intéresse pas
blonde s'est pas forcément inefficace
parce que je crois que la thèse selon
laquelle le pen va perdre beaucoup en
perdant la ligne philippot et la ligne
entre guillemets de gauche je n'y crois
pas beaucoup je pense que les électeurs
populaires qu'ils votaient le front
national je tenais pour la retraite à 60
ans parce qu'ils y croyait pas une
seconde et ils votaient pour
l'immigration et que donc le retour du
front avec les identitaires mais j'ai un
désaccord avec jérôme jaffré là dessus
le retour sur terre ne va pas lui faire
perdre et que du coup bas que vaut
qu'ils aillent sur ce terrain là pour
essayer de la contenir
en tout cas ça a du sens comme stratégie
politique dans toute chose un ca de la
chef de l'opposition et un chef qui est
déjà prétendants à la prochaine
présidentielle et de une politique qu'on
peut ne pas aimer mais qui ne sera pas
forcément dénuée d'efficacité ça a du
sens de son pendule mais c'est quand
même un peu risqué parce que ça va pas
lui permettre de rassembler au sein de
sa famille politique
si les cils et c'est effectivement sur
ces critères nous en ont parlé de
rambouillet et je suis d'accord c'était
son espace politique mais on voit bien
que il va quand même avoir un mal de
chien à rassembler
ses amis autour de cette ligne là qu'est
ce qui se passera après son élection
dans les dents dans les deux ans qui
viennent on n'en sait rien mais en tout
cas il y aura des tensions et d'une
certaine manière ça signera la fin de ce
que devait être l'ump un moment
c'est-à-dire ce grand parti de la droite
et du centre
et donc du coup est-ce que voilà est-ce
qu'il ya des petites des petites entités
des petits satellites de l'ump qui
pourraient être tentés de s'en aller
c'est pas sûr du tout non plus parce que
mais ça c'est en tout cas ce sera un
petit peu chaud à l'intérieur et au delà
de l'appareil et de et de ses amis à
l'intérieur deux des républicains je
sais pas non plus nécessairement une
ligne qui rassemble l'électorat de
droite justement sur ce point juste et
avec christian estrosi qui a écrit un
courrier à secrétaire général a bien
croyez en dix ans maintenant il faut
exclure ceux qui ont une entretenu le
doute sur leur positionnement par
rapport au front national ça ça fait
moins sympa non mais on en revient
toujours c'est la question de ses amis
est-ce qu'il va rassembler ses amis je
pense qu'aujourd'hui n'a pas d'amis il a
quasiment pas le jour où il sera patron
des républicains il aura déjà un peu
plus d'abonnements un peu plus tard et
on verra que madame portelli mével de
calan daniel fasquelle gens ont vu
participer ça ce sera le début mais il
aura encore contrôler les gros poissons
il aura contre lui bertrand pécresse
estrosi
et puis si ça marche la stratégie dont
on vient de parler c'est à dire d'aller
essayer de faire revenir notamment sa
victoire populaire à ce moment là les
amis reviendront ne pensons pas compté
mais jamais les sarkozy l'ipad amis et
puis un beau jour il avait des amis
si cette stratégie marchés leur à des
amis si cette tragi marche pas tout le
monde dira c'est un horrible droitier
faut le jeter à la poubelle et c'est
l'heure est venue de xavier bertrand
populaire et modérée ou de pécresse
efficace et gaullistes mais mais ça on
verra mais dans une procédure mais bien
moins revenus le figaro lui même sera
plus ou moins indulgent mais selon que
ça marche ou pas ce qui est normal et le
client jugera aux résultats voilà c'est
évident ouais si ça marche mais c'est
normal même politique je sais c'est pas
par hamza temps
s'il fait bien le job on dira que c'est
bien le job s'il ne le fait pas le dire
elle aurait fait mal c mais je ne savais
pas relativement sain la partie on dit
la mort de l'ump vous avez dit la fin de
l'ump dont nous c'est tout à fait vrai
est-ce que ça les parents des jugements
ça que la partie ex udf la partie sans
tri centre droit à la partie cette
sensibilité là pour ta aille chez makro
après tout ils sont d'accord ils sont
beaucoup plus d'accord cette partie là
avec ma croque avec vo ket donc que des
gens du parti socialiste qui sont
devenus des sociaux libéraux et que des
gens excédés fx et qui sont des
pro-européens modéré rejoignent mâcon
c'est ça aussi je veux dire qu'il ya peu
qui rejoint macro sea mâcon ça marche
elle restera à vos côtés d'un grand
c'était six hommes avouent qu'on ça
marchera elle reviendra en aura le rpr
avec un petit udf et ça sera très bien
et on se rend compte alors sur ce point
je vous propose justement d'écouté sur
la question de faut-il exclure pas
exclure jean louis debré et maël de
calan moi je vous dis non pas un parti
qui veut rassembler qui exclut il y
avait une solution beaucoup plus simple
c'est de ne rien dire
est-ce que les celles et ceux qui sont
partis vers les constructif aurait
repris leur adhésion aux républicains
non me résigne pas à voir les
républicains se rabougrir sur une seule
des traditions de la droite ç'a toujours
été la grande maison dans laquelle
toutes les traditions de la droite
étaient représentés la droite la plus
conservatrice et une droite moins
conservatrices une droite libérale que
j'incarne et une droite qui est de plus
en plus socialiste à certains égards sur
le plan économique que dans laquelle se
reconnaît a manifestement laurent
wauquiez tout le monde doit rester
listes que dans les républiques et c'est
peut-être pas le plus important mais en
tout cas c'est un peu le sparadrap du
capitaine haddock cette affaire
d'exclusion par l'exclusion non mais
c'est une blague
chacun son truc les
les constructive veulent se faire
exclure pour pas être les traîtres et et
les rails pour ne pas être les méchants
qui exclut c'est quand même une
plaisanterie juste on peut dire un mot
dont on va en parler on va en parler
le sondage que le studio doxa event
souffre et pour le figaro sondage qui
dit que vraiment et france info les
sympathisants et les républicains sont
très majoritairement en faveur de votre
et laurent wauquiez à 78% c'est ce qu'on
voit à l'hectare on parle bien des
sympathisants et l'air las les mêmes
sympathisants qui sont à 64% favorable à
l'exclusion dlr qui se serait trop
rapprochée emmanuel macron voilà le
demande aux français en général parce
qu'il faut qu'ils les aient toujours pas
les exclure
il faut plutôt les exclure papa par
détestation simplement parce que bon il
soit qualification de mâcon c'est plus
simple je suis jean répondu gentiment
aux sondages mais je suis sûr que c'est
dans ses conclusions non mais c'est
intéressant parce que quand on était
exclu du parti communiste dans les
années 50
d'autres ctc les séries c'était les
témoignages de tous ces gens qui on est
et qui sont partis qui ont été exclues
dans après 56 e budapest et sedar
c'était c'était et puis les gens c'était
une c'était une rupture dans leur vie
c'était un moment extrêmement difficile
à vivre parce qu'on perdait des amis on
perd des bons aujourd'hui on est dans un
parti on sort d'un parti on n'a pas pris
son sac à qui on leur prend juste avant
le congrès et puis mais tout ça n'a plus
aucune importance tout le monde s'en
fout il ya une eye et c'est cette
nouvelle politique dont on parle
beaucoup et c est là elle existe elle
existe pas mais il ya quand même quelque
chose qui est sûre c'est que le rôle des
partis leur statut leur importance dans
la société la manière dont les gens les
regardent tout ça c'est vraiment
complètement terminée quand on regarde
le baromètre de cevipof chaque année les
parties sont avec les médias tout en bas
sur la confiance c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment des institutions qui n'ont plus
de batterie le meilleur exemple du
discrédit des partis c'est que quand des
gens osent faire ce qu on oser faire
manuel valls et
de loi amont c'est à dire se présenter à
une primaire d'un parti et après quitté
ce parti c'est quand même une chose
inimaginable de de trahison d'hypocrisie
de rouerie tout ce que vous voulez et
pourquoi est-ce que ça n'a pas plus
scandalisé que ça et bien parce que
l'objet partie est tellement rejeté de
se comporter de façon épouvantable avec
un objet qu'on rejette pas si grave et
la voyez vous êtes juste pardon paul
quinio les les réactions des internautes
recettes que vous dites
nicolas sarkozy je ne m'intéresse plus
assez à la politique française pour
avoir une opinion intéressante sur le
sujet et si nous avions un vrai parti
libéral je m'y intéresserai sans doute
de nouveau georges jacques on a tourné
la page tous ces politiciens de
politiques policiers de politique
politicienne c'est fini le monde a
changé ce système est au bout de la
cinquième république qui vit ses
dernières années non sur les partis ils
sont effectivement démonétisé 1 il faut
pas s'en réjouir parce que je pense que
c'est ça fait partie des piliers de
la vie démocratique et 2,6 et lavedan
l'occurrence si on revient à l'élection
de laurent wauquiez elle est importante
parce que en fonction et alexis brézet
on parlait tout à l'heure en fonction de
la réussite ou non de macron y compris
peut-être même le parti socialiste mais
les républicains ont évidemment un rôle
très important a auront un rôle
important à jouer et le parti on
retrouvera ses muscles et ça et sa vraie
fonction donc faux faux faux je ne
jetterai pas les parties comme ça aussi
aussi rapidement et encore une fois que
je vous dis juste redire sur votre
sondage c'est un sondage de
sympathisants je pense que le jeu l'est
déjà dit tout à l'heure mais c'est passé
par là une chose et sympathisants et
l'électorat de droite
et c'est là où je pense que la ligne de
wauquiez ne me paraît pas être une ligne
capable de rassembler les lettones
l'électorat de droite sur une sur une
élection présidentielle mais on a envie
à ce que vous disiez l excellent début
la vraie question le vrai rendez vous
ces réussites au nom d'anna qu'on y
allait de il faut effacer deux
mouvements parallèles mac
wauquiez doit s'attacher à faire revenir
lectorat populaire il va donc commencer
par droitisée puis après alpha se
dérouler l'action de macron qui va
marcher ou pas marché et moins elle
marchera plus wauquiez a tendance à se
recentrer vers la fin pour faire revenir
ses sens paysan les ans les revenus à la
maison va gagner ensemble et à ce moment
là les centristes diront s'il ya
possibilité de gagner 0
sinon recentrer il va avoir du mal à
recentrer son discours en face ils
peuvent bien sûr qu'ils aient sarkozy
l'a fait sarkozy ça le reste il a été
élu président de république après tout
c'est parce que ça passe encore que ça
parce que je vous le dit paul quinio de
poster
la vieille la sirte oil aussi que ça m'a
plu c'est toujours du comparatif ci si
effectivement il ya un affaissement aux
verts le sens de macron aujourd'hui il
aura un espace le lit des ailes parce
que on parlait des partis les clivages
les différents enjeux ne correspondent
plus bon c'est une banalité de le dire
aux frontières des partis on le voit
bien aujourd'hui partout mais le la
stratégie de wauquiez c'est sur
l'électorat s'est pas tellement les
parties l'ailé est ce que c'est
l'ancienne udf etc c'est vraiment ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le bloc
conservateur sur le conservateur ces
conservateurs sur la société c'est
mariage pour tous c'est des
conservatismes au sens lié à la
tradition je vais aller vite catholique
pompe au centre est très classique
et puis le bloc populaire donc ça c'est
on avait c'était patrick buisson en son
temps qu'elle est qu'il y avait un peu
théorisé la chose pour une que la
sarkozye est un sas et c'est l'enjeu
principal pour une droite aujourd'hui
qui veut maîtriser la menace front
national sur son aile droite et qui veut
avec des centristes européenne et ses
amis qui sont plus conservateurs que les
sociaux-libéraux 1 c'est ça la grande
différence olivier duhamel encore sur
droite-gauche plus tellement sur
l'économie c'est vraiment sur la
question des valeurs que ça se joue et
donc là effectivement il ya une
possibilité si laurent wauquiez ainsi
sur ces questions s'il n'est pas sur une
question économique où il va dire mais
on fera pas le budget parce que nous on
s'oppose mais en fait proposé c'était
aussi à des problèmes avant ses ennuis
de campagne de françois fillon qui
proposait d'aller un peu plus loin qu
emmanuel macron mais on voyait qu'il
avait pas une différence de nature
c'était plutôt de degrés donc c'est pas
là dessus que ça marche il faut des
différences de nature en politique les
clivages ce sont des différences de
nature
donc il arrive là à le faire wauquiez il
aura il aura il pourra les degrés quand
c'est difficile parce que quand il est
là ça c'est de cette 16e sila le ya deux
jours ou même peut-être hier ils étaient
obligés de faire marche arrière sur la
après la déclaration de sens commun en
dix ans
qui avait dit voilà on pourrait
éventuellement s'entendre avec mario
rinaldo facebook était obligé de parce
que marion maréchal-le pen ça risque
d'être sa véritable agression ensuite à
nos sources pour lui elle pourrait avoir
la même stratégie si elle revenait dans
la drôme mais à partir du franc et les
sursauts sur ses fondamentaux
identitaire jeu complètement d'accord
avec vous c'est son créneau
et vous voyez bien que y compris sur son
créneau il obligeait très trop près
d'aller à la première incartade
tactiquement parce qu'il n'est
absolument pas intérêt ce qu on esquive
aussi le savez que ce qui ne veut pas
donc deux niveaux venir les affronter
l'électorat il va pas fixer la direction
du front national il n'y a pas intérêt
comment faire une série de sociétés
parce que il faut au moins distinguer
les questions immigration sécurité
des questions demeurent des champions
aura pas de majorité pour des luttes
populaires ne suis pas forcément le vrai
point commence d'agression diderot table
immigration c'est que c'est là la scène
française comme wayne a pas de
l'électorat commun à construire sur la
finition n'est pas de classe moteur
essentiel de sélection autre sujet
d'actualité mélenchon valls
la tension monte chaque jour d'un cran
entre les deux le leader la france a
soumis streiff l'ancien premier ministre
de l'asile manuel valls accuse à son
tour mélenchon de jouer avec le feu d'un
nouvel antisémitisme qui fait le jeu de
l'islam radical
regardez manuel valls il était ce matin
l'invité d'europe 1 et quand on dit que
je suis l'ami de l'extrême droite
israélienne
au fond on veut partie un seul message
dire que manuel valls est l'ami des
juifs et je mets des guillemets et c'est
là où il ya une complaisance
c'est là où jean luc mélenchon ses amis
ne se rendent pas compte
ou alors ils s'en rendent compte et ce
encore plus grave que l'antisémitisme ou
l'anti sionisme
ce nouvel antisémitisme d'aujourd'hui
est au coeur de la matrice de
l'idéologie totalitaire de l'islamisme
radical olivier duhamel vous étiez
sévère tout à l'heure sur manuel valls
mais il a raison sur ce point
oui c'est un autre sujet quand même pas
la même énergie
écoutez d'un côté les injures qui se
jettent l'année l'autre à la figure j'ai
même pas envie d'en parler parce qu'ils
font ça aussi pour que occupé le devant
de la scène et dans le fond quand on les
reprend d'entretien vous avez bien fait
de prendre ce passage parce que là au
moins c'est un pansement la bastille par
rapport avec le fond mais quand ils
traitent de fachos de match de la
difficulté la plus stricte concernant il
ya un vrai débat ya une vraie question
est une vraie question qui est posée et
pas seulement à valcea mélenchon mais
plus largement dans le pays sur derrière
des positions neutres un pro
palestinienne est dite antisioniste est
ce qu'il n'ya pas la montée d'un
antisémitisme qui n'ose pas dire son nom
et est-ce qu'on ne flatte pas cet
antisémitisme auprès de couches de la
population qui sont sensibles ça rejoint
ce qu'on disait c'est un peu le
symétrique de la question identitaire à
droite
donc là on est à gauche donc il ya
plusieurs choses rapidement rappelé que
jean luc mélenchon et manuel valls se
connaissent très bien ils ont passé 30
ans semble parti social dans les soldats
nissan tous les deux donc ils se
connaissent parfaitement
donc il ya aujourd'hui une exacerbation
d'une rivalité qui est déjà ancienne et
il y as je suis d'accord avec olivier ce
domaine et je complète l'un était
rocardien valff voilà ont été introduits
au mitterrandien se font la guerre
donc il y a de la posture la wii ça
monte très vite dans les cordes par ce
que il ya une posture il ya une non pas
humaine il faut pas exagérer mais un
antagonisme viscérale là au fond en
revanche ont rejoint quand même des
questions et la posture ce parfois colle
avec la réalité de la structure de deux
il ya un enjeu fondamental et jean luc
mélenchon n'est pas idiot il a regardé
ses résultats électoraux à la
présidentielle et aux législatives et où
est-ce qu'il a eus ces gros scores ou
est ce qu'il a fait c'est gros scores
dans des endroits notamment chez les
jeunes et dans les quartiers populaires
dans la périphérie des grandes villes
notamment en banlieue parisienne vont
ont été élus principalement ou dans des
circonscriptions de ce type ont été
élues ses députés et là on a
effectivement ce que disait olivier
duhamel c'est à dire aujourd'hui une
partie de l'électorat qui est un
électorat pour lequel israël question
israélo palestinienne pour lequel les
juifs de manière générale correspondent
à des images qui sont liées à
l'antisémitisme au sens classique
antisionisme antisémitisme et donc il ne
dit pas c'est jean luc mélenchon il
n'est pas devenu antisémite
il n'est pas devenu non laïque et pas du
tout républicain tout d'un coup c'est
pas ça mais il ne peut pas compte tenu
de son électorat compte tenu de ce
qu'est la france insoumise avec des
députés comme danièle obono et c'est
avec clémentine autain il ne peut pas il
ne peut pas risquer d'apparaître comme
le laïc intransigeant parce que il l'est
il est très sûr la laïcité la république
jean luc mélenchon ça fait très
longtemps il a eu comme conseiller henri
pena ruiz etc
c'est quelqu'un qui est de la question
c'est quel est le peuple de la gauche et
on voit la côte et valls côté mélenchon
deux conceptions ils ont compris que
macro n'est pas le peuple gens se dit
moi j'ai besoin électorat populaire
aujourd'hui il ne l'a pas et et on sent
que enfin que la vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
yann quand on regarde lectorat populaire
fond il ya deux électorats ya un
électorat pour aller vite et deux pour 4
sécurité mais petit blanc tentés par le
front national est un peu lectorat
plutôt d'origine immigrée qui est sûr le
se soucier de crise lui boeuf et et on a
senti que mélenchon a hésité pendant
toute la campagne présidentielle sur
l'europe et l'asie
entre les deux et là il est en train
notamment à cause de ses alliés de
basculer du côté de cet électorat
d'origine immigrée qui sait la
remettront un électorat populaire parce
qu'il se dit macron l'aura pas eh ben on
se dit qu'il va essayer de prendre cet
électorat un petit blanc enfin petit
blanc c'est pas péjoratif c'est que tu
auras autochtones 2e hier soir apple
dans la gauche de gouvernement la colère
sociale et je n'ai par contre la passe
vers un point aveugle sur ces questions
d'identité de rapport à la nation de
rapports la frontière de rapport à la
place de la religion dans la société
naturex est certain c'est là dessus que
manuel valls et c'est logiquement la
gauche dit d'ailleurs aujourd'hui macron
n'ont trouvé le moyen de lui parler
d'une autre façon que le fond il faut
lui parler et le respectent et se
mettant de rentrer façon sauf que là je
suis complètement d'accord avec ce que
vous avez dit laurent bouvet et du coup
je me dis que jean luc mélenchon n'est
pas à la hauteur du personnage qu'il est
parce que il est moi j'aurais aimé
l'entendre dénoncé les propos de la
députée obono sûr j'ai pleuré pour
dieudonné j'ai pas pleurer pour charlie
ou après l'histoire du 2
du conducteur de la ratp qui refusait de
conduire un bus après après une femme
c'est des propos qui ne peuvent pas être
tenus par une députée républicaine et
jean luc mélenchon
je suis convaincu qu'au fond de lui il
est en désaccord avec ses excès avec ses
propos et il reste ambiguë par tactique
électorale ça c'est pas bien c'est pas
bien c'est la définition de du
clientélisme électoral de la lecture des
résultats électoraux d'une forme de
réalité qui serra mais malgré ces
conneries il a une logique qui peut
paraître cynique mais en politique ça
existe qui est d'un réalisme cru il ne
peut pas désavouer danièle obono ce
malgré ses propos très très
très enfin tout à fait ça a été pire a
qualifié assez choquant il ne peut pas
la désavouer il se tait il va pas lui
dire bravo bravo danièle ses superbes
asie continue certainement parmi ce que
je vais dire quelque chose qui va
choquer tous mes amis quand y'a un élu
du front national qui il est sanctionné
sur le charbon sur le jeu après un ça va
très vite
olivier duhamel je vous annonce que
françoise aller at a dit je suis
d'accord avec vous surtout j'ai tout
seul de notes sur cette polémique oui
allez vous le soulignez alexis l'est
aussi quand même un peu déliées
querelles de de l'essonne qui est reçue
alors c'est vraiment mal et là il ya une
dimension de jongler stratégie qui peut
sembler intéressante pour l'avenir que
des questions de bons hommes qui se
détestent ça c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave pas passionnant ça joue un rôle
mais ça va avec
y compris la bataille de la bataille
dans l'essonne qui n'est pas terminée la
sélection anglaise
la question soumise si la partielle de
nouvelles cellules être adulé enfin il
ya plein d'enjeux d'ailleurs tout ça non
mais ce qui est grave
je maintiens mais vous avez raison pour
des raisons de calcul électoral ou de
pesanteur électorale on pousse le
cynisme au point de porter atteinte à
des principes absolument fondamentaux on
est censé jusque-là défendre et qui
censé être partagée par beaucoup plus de
gens que de mélenchon au moins ils
partageaient ça avec beaucoup et faire
des exceptions des entorses des silences
des simagrées des contournements là
dessus si grave c'est beaucoup plus
grave que les agents dans la campagne à
sa gauche des gens qui finalement ont
voté pour lui critiqué le fait qu'il met
en avant les drapeaux bleu blanc dans
ses réseaux dans ses meetings parce que
il a accentué ce fait par rapport à sa
campagne de 2012 et il a vraiment on se
rappelle du meeting à la république
notamment une forêt alors corps de blanc
l'a vu ce meeting de marseille japon où
il sur les plages du prado avec les
embauches et surtout vous qu'il vivait
dans leurs côtés d'invités année venez
tous enfin vous avez
la universal lui étaient reprochés dans
son propre visite chaque fois entre ces
deux farceurs il rassemble tout ce qui
est à gauche deux du social il rassemble
toutes les familles il ya des anciens
trotskistes il ya des communistes il ya
des gauchistes qui peut or hors
catégorie si vous voulez y a des il ya
des gens qui sont dans le ce qu'on
appelle ce qu'on appelait le mouvement
this la gauche mouvements qui s'était il
rassemble tout ça et aussi des petits
morceaux des socialistes des
républicains des et donc c'est quand
même
il essaie de faire quelque chose là qui
est quand même très compliqué
politiquement on dit que c'est compliqué
pour tout le monde on parlait de laurent
wauquiez on pourrait parler d' emmanuel
macron il essaie lui aussi il a ses
difficultés
et donc là il a compris que c'était la
manière de ne surtout pas désespérés non
pas billancourt mais les quelques ses
positions effectivement sur sur les
sujets dont on peut même parler à mon
avis ils l'empêchent de rassembler plus
largement à gauche
chacune d'elle est d'élargir notamment
auprès des électeurs du parti socialiste
qui aura pu être tenté par mélenchon sur
les questions économiques et sociales
nous n'ont pas voté pour lui à cause de
ses positions sur les questions
identitaires sur les quais sur la
question de l'islamisme radical et
stains et puis je pense qu'il ya une
dimension psychique
c'est un personnage devenu assez
largement mégalomane et qui justement
quand on cherche et quand on critique
s'enfonce dans son erreur regardez
regardez par exemple son comportement
vis-à-vis du venezuela aujourd'hui il
dit quelles que soient les critiques que
j'aurai à faire je le ferai pas parce
que vous me demandez de faire je ne le
ferai pas parce que l'ennemi c'est la
mairie c'est la même chose
il trébuche un peu il commet une erreur
on vient de pointer là dessus et bien
justement jamais ça c'est vraiment une
dimension qui compte dans l'explication
alors vous évoquiez les drapeaux meeting
ça c'est une autre polémique qu'il a
allumé jean luc mélenchon ils réclament
en vain le retrait du drapeau européen
de l'assemblée nationale emmanuel macron
entend lui le graver dans le marbre la
présence de ce drapeau
dernier argument date avancée par jean
luc mélenchon les douze étoiles sur fond
bleu serait inspiré d'un symbole
religieux celui de la couronne de mabri
regardez le ainsi que alexis corbière il
on parle tous les deux et franchement on
est obligé de supporter ça
maintenant danser la république
française je sais pas la vierge marie
son créateur monsieur arthur heinze l'a
toujours assumé
c'est un symbole religieux cette
symbolique du fond bleu et ses deux
étoiles est directement inspirée de la
médaille pieuse dédié à la vierge marie
que monsieur à porter autour du cou
c'est un symbole mariale volontairement
adopté le 8 décembre 55 le jour de
l'immaculée conception
pourtant plus que jamais nous avons
besoin de laïcité il importe que les
symboles présent dans cette assemblée
soit conforme à cette volonté qui nous
rassemble oui laïcité mais objectivement
il a raison il attend de redécouvrir un
truc qui s'appelle les racines
chrétiennes de l'europe alors que l'irak
n'a même pas eu mais c'est vrai que
quand on a fait le drapeau européen
l'idée c'était celle des prêts contre cc
voilà ce que je rappelle juste que tous
comprennent c'est arsène x risque
d'inquiéter ses monnaies c'est le
schumann sévérité choummaly machin a
choisi la salle al karkhi d'afghans
téléray thalacap id apps que stigmatiser
l'europe parce que c'est con mais c'est
moi je la stigmatise pas mais c'est le
mélange noir et rose et le drapeau
européen et effet les l'europe est une
construction des démocrates chrétiens
qui se sont appuyés sur notamment le
texte de l'apocalypse sur la sainte
vierge avec la lune et sous ses pas et
les couronnes couronné des toiles pour
pour le palais adopté parce que s'ils me
la faculté pour ceinture parce que jouer
au ballon mais n'ont pas découvert sur
l'ailé sur inspiration robert schuman et
béate il est en voie de béatification
lac la barre et une bonne et elles ont
bien fait
calais s'arrêtant çà fait les racines
chrétiennes de l'europe dont il n'y a
pas que des racines chrétiennes des
métallos drapeau et la magnifique
ballade servait mélenchon s'en sort des
sommes récupérées sont catholiques
il ya effectivement lieu des 30 la scène
comme des balles et quand on regarde les
couleurs effectivement ça fait penser à
la vierge marie
c'est très controversé et l'usagé qui en
est fait là la question pour les ce qui
est intéressant dans ce que dit jean luc
mélenchon ce que disaient les sleecs en
bière c'est effectivement qu'il
redécouvre ils se sont à nouveau les
laïcs et presque pour utiliser le
méchant mots de maurras laïcards c'est à
dire en exaltant comme ça la république
contrôler la vierge marie patronne
sainte patronne de lampes des trucs
alors que on vient de le dire avant
quand il s'agit d'une autre religion en
l'occurrence plutôt l'islam et surtout
les islamistes et la manière dont
danièle obono a fait ces déclarations
alors là c'est une les lie à géométrie
narnia dalli cité non alors là c'est la
tolérance c'est très bien on n'a rien à
dire finalement et c'est beaucoup mieux
c'était la liste que la récupération
catholique a redonné alexis corbière qui
regardent les armes de montreuil il
était vieux de montreuil s'il ya une
fleur de lys sur les armements taille
ces catholiques et marseille c'est qu'on
est loin du grand pau de marseille une
croix bleue et la république la
république c'est quoi ça charles péguy
la république notre royaume de france et
notre royaume de france pourquoi ce qui
est important c'est notre c'est à dire
que nous sommes tous voilà les héritiers
de cela je vous propose de faire un peu
encore histoire une histoire un peu plus
lointaine en saluant le prix figaro
histoire alexis qui a été remis hier à
philippe contamine philippe contamine
dans le livre s'intitule charles vii une
vie une politique
donc là on est à l'ancienne la gêne et
un autre est temps d'arrêt
et donc c'est il a été récompensé et le
prix est attribué par un panel
d'historiens et la journaliste est bel
et bien merci beaucoup merci à tous les
quatre mais restez avec nous restez pas
ce que nous allons retrouver dans un
instant ariane le coeur ariane le coeur
qui va nous présenter un focus sur les
super model alors qu'ils sont les super
model ce sont les top modèles des années
90 elles sont aujourd'hui femme
d'affaires mère de famille elles font
encore rêver les marques et explose et
internet
merci encore et on retrouve point de vue
demain demain pour une nouvelle édition
présentée par guillaume roquette merci à
tous les 4 1
[Musique]